Attorney General Jeff Sessions promises
to leave no stone unturned to find
missing text messages tied to the Russia
investigation Republicans say the text
may show bias by the FBI's Peter struck
and Lisa page who once worked for
Special Counsel Robert Muller well this
morning on Twitter President Trump
called it one of the biggest stories in
a long time writing quote the FBI now
says it's missing five months worth of
lovers struck page text perhaps 50,000
and all in primetime Wow exclamation
point
Paula Reed is tracking the investigation
Paula good morning good morning now
struck played a key role in the Clinton
email investigation and was then
assigned to the Muller probe that he was
dismissed after his anti-trump text
messages were discovered and now the
revelation that the FBI was not storing
many texts during this critical period
between the presidential transition and
the day Muller was appointed is setting
off a political firestorm we need to get
to the bottom of and find out what
exactly happened Republicans in Congress
are asking why hundreds of messages are
missing between FBI officials Peter
struck and Lisa Paige who exchanged
thousands of texts frequently discussing
the Clinton investigation as well as
their dislike of Trump in one from
February 2016 Paige texted struck then
candidate Trump simply cannot be
President in another struck calls Trump
an idiot and awful no charges are
appropriate in this case struck and
Paige also discussed Comey statement
exonerating Hillary Clinton's use of a
private email server an earlier draft
noted Secretary Clinton emailed with
President Obama from her private server
but the sentence was later edited to
replace the president with a senior
government official struck and Paige
also discussed using non-work phones to
talk about Clinton so it can't be traced
during the Department of Justice's
investigation into struck it found texts
were missing between December 14 2016
and May 17 27 teen those dates span the
presidential transition and the day
Robert Muller was appointed the FBI
blamed software
and technical issues saying employees
with many Samsung five mobile devices
did not capture texts during that time
it's very serious to me I have somebody
inside was last month on Face the Nation
Republican Senator James Lankford said
Struck's comments are also calling you
to question his role on the Miller probe
it's clear this individual within the
Muller team that was also on the Clinton
email investigation team had a strong
bias against now president trauma
yesterday FBI director Chris Rea visited
the White House to discuss the five
months of missing text that appeared
impact of many more agents in addition
to struck in Paige now struck is
expected to testify on Capitol Hill soon
but a date has not been set
Gail all right a lot to discuss there -
thank you very much Paula